翻訳: Kayoko Shiomi
校正: Shoko Takaki
39歳の春
自宅近くに開店したばかりの絨毯屋で
１枚のペルシャ絨毯を購入しました
今はその絨毯を見るたびに
巡り合わせの不思議さを感じています
１枚の絨毯を買ったことで
イランという国に興味を持ち
イラン映画をよく観るようになりました
当時私は 映画を見ることは好きでしたが
映画を作るのに何が必要か全く知らず
将来自分が映画プロデューサーになるとは
思いもよりませんでした
では なぜ主婦だった私が
40歳にして映画を作り始めたのか
きっかけは10歳になる娘との約束
「あなたを主演に映画を作ってあげるから
受けた仕事はやり通しなさい」でした
というのも 娘がオーデイションを受け
出演が決まった映画の内容が
どうにも納得いかず
おまけに制作会社が資金難で
劇場公開が危ぶまれていたからです
そこで私は 日本とイランの子供達が主演の
映画の構想を練り
日本の大手映画会社に
企画の売り込みにいきました
ところがどの会社も
「原作がないから無理だよ」
「子供が映画じゃヒットしないよ」
「経験がないから駄目だ」と
全く相手にされません
ああ 日本では経験がないと
映画作りは無理なんだな
と諦めていた時に
子供が主演のイラン映画
『運動靴と赤い金魚』が
アカデミー賞外国映画賞を受賞した
というニュースを聞き
「あ これだ！
イランの映画会社とだったら
私が無名でも
何とかなるかもしれない」と思い
翌週にはイランに飛んで
（笑）
イランの有名な監督に
「映画を一緒に作りましょう」と
お願いしていました
イランの監督は 日本と違って
「どういうお話？」と
ただ それだけ聞くので
「日本とイランの子供が主役で
縦軸をペルシャ絨毯に
心温まるお話を作りたい」と
身振り手振り交えながら
説得しましたら
「いいお話だね　楽しくなるよ
やりましょう」という流れになり
その場で仮契約をして
手付金まで置いて
日本に戻ってきました
しかし それからが
悲劇の始まりでした
（笑）
映画プロデユーサーとして大切なことは
物語の骨格を決め
映画監督を決め
製作資金を集め
契約をむすぶことです
私は 監督はイラン人
制作資金は何とかなったものの
契約のところで
大変な失敗をしました
事前に弁護士のチェックを受け
双方で合意した契約内容の１ページ
「ワールドセールスは日本側にある」
という内容が なぜか
「イラン側にある」と
書き替えられていたんです
それを見落としてサイン
イラン側が契約寸前に
書類をすり替えていたようなんですね
そうとも知らず
日本に戻り配給会社に契約書を見せたら
「益田さん なぜ確認しないで
サインしたんですか！
これでは出資はできません」
と言われてしました
イラン側は
「サインしたのはあなたでしょ」
サインした私が悪いと言います
この契約書が有効になってしまったら
映画はイランのものになってしまう
私は居てもたってもいられず
翌週 単身イランに飛び
イラン側の製作者に
強く抗議しました
するとその上司が出てきて
「契約書を作り直してあげるから
いくら払えるんだ」と こう来ました
「えっ？
私は映画を作るために
貯金はすべて使った 車も売った
家も担保にお金借りました
もう売るものはない
これでは日本に帰れない」と
怒りがだんだん だんだん
もうこみ上げてきて
その場で持ってきた契約書を全部
ビリビリ ビリビリ破り始めました
そして 涙が出てきたんです
イラン側は「どうして契約書を破るんだ」と
「やっ これは紙だから
契約書が鉄でできていたら破れない」
と切り返すと
さすがに
泣きながら契約書を破る交渉相手の
覚悟を理解してか
しぶしぶ 契約書を作り直してくれる
ことになりました
（拍手）
今思えば 本当に素人だったと思います
その後 仲良くなったイラン人から
こんなアドバイスをいただきました
「人間は悩めば悩むほど神に近づく
君も少しだけ 神に近づいたね」と
映画『風の絨毯』は
中東のアカデミー賞と言われる
ファジール国際映画祭で
観客賞を含む３賞を受賞しました
東京―
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
東京国際映画祭でも特別招待作品となり
話題になりました
しかし 映画は
ヒットしなかったんです
私はお金を失いました
その時に
映画に出演してくださっていた—
今は亡き 日本の名優
三國連太郎さんから
こんなこと言われました
「君はイランと映画を作ったことで
これだけの人脈を得て
これだけの経験をしたんだから
この経験を もう１本映画を作って
あなたの財産にしないと
財産にしなさい」と励まされました
２作目の『平成職人の挑戦』は
私の故郷 飛騨高山の
祭屋台の復元にかける
職人たちの生きざまを描いた
ドキュメンタリー映画です
この映画も当初 映画関係者からは
「職人の映画なんて誰が見るんだ？
興行的に大失敗するからやめなさい」と
耳打ちされました
しかし「映画は興行だけが
全てではない」と思い
出演してくれた職人達に
協力を求めたところ
このパワーが凄かった
京都から始まった劇場公開は
全国に広がり
日本の大手ものづくりの企業
そして技術系の大学が
続々支援に回ってくれました
「あっ
何のために映画を作る[のか]
という目的がはっきりしていれば
認めてくれるんだなっていうことを
第２作目で学びました
日本には「語りべ」
といわれる長老がいて
日本の伝統文化や
先人達の哲学を
語って 次の世代に
子供達に伝えていました
ところが 現在は核家族化[で]
そうした風習も
だんだん少なくなってきています
そこで私は その「語りべ」の役を
映像にして次の世代に伝えたい
これが私の使命だなと
感じるようになりました
最近 劇場公開した映画に
『サンマとカタール』があります
日本と
イランとペルシャ湾を挟んで
立地する中東の国 カタール
このカタールとの映画は
2011年 東日本大震災が起きた時
壊滅的な被害を受け
復興は不可能だと言われた—
サンマで有名な町 女川町が
若者のエネルギーを結集して
復興のトップランナーとなるまでを
描いた記録映画です
復興の後押しをしたのは
カタールでした
ではなぜ カタールが
女川町を支援したのでしょう？
カタールは 今でこそ
世界で最も裕福な国となっていますが
1930年代
天然ガスが発掘されるまでは
天然真珠と漁業を中心とした
小さな国でした
その天然ガスを
日本の技術と経済支援によって
液化天然ガスにして
世界に輸出できるよう
カタール経済の基盤を作ったのが
日本なんです
ですから カタール政府は
東日本大震災が起きた時
どの国よりも早く いの一番で
「カタールフレンド基金」を作り
恩返しのための支援をしました
「マスカー」（大型冷凍冷蔵庫）
これが カタールから支援をしてくれた
大型冷蔵庫なんです
これです
津波対応を施したこの大型蔵庫は
女川町のシンボルになり
「女川は再びサンマ日本一になるんだ」
っていう夢を
人々に与えています
「死んだ人は 生きている人の
心の中に生き続けている
だから生かされている俺たちは熱い！」
これは 映画に登場してくれた
女川町の皆さんの言葉です
この姿を 世界に発信したい
そして カタールだけではなく
日本は東日本大震災が起きた時
世界中から
いろんな支援を受けました
映像を通してその感謝を伝えたい
これが映画の持つ「力」だと思います
映画製作 始めは素人でしたが
15年もこの業界で働いていると
だんだん名前が知られるようになり
いろんな企画が
持ち込まれるようになりました
最近 性同一性障害[と]
LGBTを扱った映画を製作し
話題になり 劇場公開しました
これですね
『ハイヒール革命』です
この映画も 当初
大手の映画会社からは
企画が却下された作品です
映画はもちろん「ロマン」が大切です
しかし 最後は「ソロバン」なんです
映画は お金をどう集め
どう使っていくかが大切なんです
ですから
出資してくださろうとしている皆さんには
「お金は墓場まで
持っていくことはできません
映画の興行で
お金はお返しできないかもしれませんが
あなたの名前とその思いは
映画の中に永遠に残ります
ですから 私と楽しく
遊びながら映画作りをしませんか？」
と微笑みかけながら
今までたくさんの方に
協力いただきながら
十数本の映画を
作ることができました
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
嬉しい
（拍手）
私の映画製作は
思いを共有する皆さんと
「夢は大きく 志は高く 仕事は楽しく」
がモットーです
たまにはヒットしてもらいたい
とも思いますが
（笑)
大切なことは
人々の「思い」を
映像にして次の世代に伝えることです
そして 「100年先まで残る
現代の語りべ」となりたいんです
これからの映画製作
皆さんの心に残る映画を
全身全霊
作り続けていきたいと思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）